[Applaudissements]
à troyes et l'a23 version très bien
merci
voilà tu vas dans la gueule ça ce sera
faire tu vas t'en dis tu vas prendre son
erre dans ta tronche et à la subite
voilà regarde derrière je vais te le
faire attention attention c'est le
dernier est là aux gens pourquoi c'est
le maxi bonus celui qui gagne celui ci
il va vraiment s'acharner sur l'autre
d'accord j'ai un objet surprise que ce
soit pour toi et pour moi aussi c'est
comme ça qu'on m'appelle quand je suis
chez moi je suis tout nous on m'appelle
l'objet surprise ou et oui et je te dis
je suis but plutôt douloureux que l'oeuf
kinder tant mieux pour toi attention
quand même car cinq cartes donc là sa
cinquième est la bonne
la cinquième et la bloquer j'aimerais
qu'on met un petit peu de musique de
suspense s'il te plaît alors ici ça peut
partir à tout moment
mais attention cible est à doser année
net 1 j'ai pas d'as 2g que des à cela
c'est bien c'est bien c'est les 3 plein
d'effets de lumière ça sert à rien parce
que ici je vais faire des lumières mais
en fait tu qu'on voit plus rien les
chaluts mais tout simplement que les
gens nous voient
merci 4g que des garçons il a chanté
genre en une carte de mer alors c'est
quoi j'avais la colle sur le front et
toi tu me la met sur le banc and away
invasive relâcheront oui oui lâche vos
frocs à lille c'était la dernière voir
les vrais rivasi la chaume oprah
ça jure sur la coupe l'erreur de had je
suis blau bas badiane honnête tu n'as
comme ça j'ai triche pas tu ne triche
pas ta carte d'affaires de merck 1 2 à 3
que ta carte non non tu es la voir aller
moi j'aime la surprise j'aime ou j'aime
le jeu j'aime le rythme tranquille vu
des preuves
qu'est-ce que je te kiffe à 2 3 aux
punaises dans la carte de merde
[Applaudissements]
jésus
non
[Musique]
à
football
c'est gratuit et c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
seras tu veux à données comparables
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est évidemment le mexique est
sandra on a hâte de vous retrouver
demain sur quelle femme chocolat va dire
ça mais on essaye pas je vais te le
mettre dans le bain la voix savoir c'est
quoi votre avis il est dur où il est mou
sur dur ici les mots et les durs
j'avais 12 ans je ne comprends pas alors
dès qu'est ce qu'elle a voulu dire que
tu es prêt le partage ça s'est passé
quoi on va prendre des cours d'anglais
attention
[Applaudissements]
c'est n'importe quoi c'est n'importe
quoi
alors la cabine et des actions sont
uniquement pour des pmp c'est vrai ça
fait du bien elle dit merci les chez
vous vous doutez bien que mon oreillette
ne marche plus c'est non plus surtout
aimable et tout est ok c'est vrai je
vais le mettre
j'ai envie de le mettre tout de suite un
réseau